permettez-moi de me présenter, je m'appelle
Malcolm Adekanbi, quelles chaussures tu portes
oh oui, viens à propos de celles-là en ce moment
Malcolm Adekanbi est un geek
dont les amis Diggie et Jim sont aussi
des geeks tout ce que je veux faire c'est reprendre facilement
dans une salle blanche calme je vais dire
quelque chose c'est juste arrogant Malcolm Jib
et Diggy ne font pas de sport et ils
ne sont plus là, ils sont toujours
ridiculisés parce qu'ils aiment les
trucs blancs comme avoir de bonnes notes et aller
à l'université ne s'effondrent pas quand notre senior
est ici  est-ce que Tom a commencé à élargir nos
horizons, nous n'allons pas à une
fête d'anniversaire de trafiquants de drogue,
c'est si réel, comment as-tu organisé cette fête,
telle est la vie d'un geek, ne mélange pas ce que
tu n'es pas, ce que je ne vais pas faire avec un sac à dos.
a-t-il réellement dit que je vous tuerais, vous et
vos amis, si vous ne vous débarrassez pas de
ces drogues ou si vous n'agissez pas comme si
vous n'étiez pas curieux aussi, nous ne savons
rien des drogues, vous le savez, nous devons
savoir  si tu veux nous aider, je ne
veux pas aller en prison, je veux aller à l'
université, je
ne peux pas me faire tomber,
qui penses-tu que tu es, es-tu réel,
es-tu un faux ? Qui suis-je,
permets-moi de me réintroduire mon  le nom
est peux-tu le creuser